the uk is set to see more devastation as
it's hit by a third named storm in just
one week
flood warnings in parts of manchester
have been upgraded to severe meaning
there is a threat to life from my own
experience i've seen many people have
traumatized after being fled their homes
flooded it's a something that sticks
with you for a long long time please be
aware that that isn't the peak of it
there's more to come so please don't be
thinking that it's not as high i'm not
worried please do take action at this
point more than 420 properties across
northern and west and east didsbury have
been identified as being key risk
because of rising levels of the river
mersey
all this comes as work continued to
repair the damage left behind from storm
units
uk power network says the weather caused
a month's worth of faults in just one
day
with very high speed winds uh it can
cause uh conductors on our overhead
lines to clash the most common cause is
is trees or debris from trees being
blown off and blown into power lines or
trees themselves being blown over
completely by the by the speed speed of
the winds power has been restored to
most of those who faced outages but two
days after eunice struck telephone lines
are still down in parts of kent
work to restore the damage is slow
because the threat of another deadly
storm is so close
sadia chowdhury sky news in chittington
in kent